[Musique]
scott a même cité sans fil aux adultes
qu'aux faits 1/2 sommes quasiment du roi
abdallah se déplacer tout seul tout ça
ne vient pas pour tout le monde
[Musique]
ce feu là bas
ce choix de ce feu dans
et ça pète shah titre ce fut la bonne
etc
et ça paie touati c'est comme mon blog
au fond de l'affairé
hp de viol maintenant les consciences
[Musique]
home depot nous
non
[Musique]
monde
k
non
[Musique]
oh
qui ça tourne sous ces fonds dans sa
peinture se ferait en effet le tout
celle-ci du coup ça pulse elle c'est une
reprise d'un artiste heureusement boots
appétit
tu relevé que pour les caméras les a pas
photo je le vis que pour les miroirs le
regard des jo
le jeune coco topher change oui je sors
mais c'est toi tout c'est vrai
torture que paul k
et jean
ni jésus jésus que ne sorte je ne fais
que dans le virtuel
pour notre jeu n'a plus aucun mystère
l'egypte aussi courte que les nuits de
ton père
tu regarde tout ce que je
[Musique]
mais tu ne veux pas te fais encore en
soi tu vois il y aurait tous et même
jusqu'à samedi
tu vas rentrer seul si je ne sais pas
les clubs bref encore un jour où tu te
dis que pour les caméras
sa peau
oh
[Musique]
quelques pots
regarde ce jour
le jeu
coco
de fins en jeu ça
[Musique]
masato coûte souvent
tu me jure que par cas
[Musique]
jo
jean-paul
[Musique]
ce n'est pas la peine on les adore elle
use ont plu scot la quarantaine que ti
amo et ce tous les hommes ça
joli que ce tout ce qu'ils veulent du
coup il tonne ce qui est beau
parce qu'avec ton sens avec ton 106
ça
[Musique]
celle ci a fait de stupide plein combat
beaucoup d'opinions sur iton vacallo a
beaucoup bien c'est un accord de pêche
joe borg
[Musique]
ce n'est de quoi
faubert west
ce système instauré la main sur ce thème
serait nommé de ce changement
voici des accusés sans vrai
[Musique]
pour tous
t
vous
tout est beau
[Musique]
ce peuple est votée
marie-hélène du passage d'un seul bloc
[Musique]
enfin ce choc c'est comme ça
l'histoire de jake kasdan
à l'époque
bon je te plaît
teuhpu temps
pour sue
et pourtant ce que tout est de tel
temps
[Musique]
stockholm
oh
e
[Musique]
toi tu peur du sang mais pas la tête
norkom lula meftaz ap quand celle que tu
attends tout à fait pas sa tech seul sur
la terre seule la mia personnes invite
se lave de tout comment faire ça je veux
les plus tristes cacher quand mon père
chien dernier sourire se roule dans mon
père c'est toujours les mêmes problèmes
tu nous avais et nous empêche de dormir
musée tél en somme plus en l'avenir au
soccer
j'en garde laluque en leur fournissant
voix séparant la ville vous héberge ne
peut pas perdre ma justice être par la
nature cette fille qui s'énerve même si
ta valise et lourdes emporte la trop de
plat plat les gens ici sont des pros de
la plaque ou drôles et sourire d'abba et
demanderont jamais ce que les soucis tu
apportes se jetant la reine d'adobe les
palettes au seul gène a method ges des
crises ans
je me suis levé c'est bon j'ai vu ce que
je pouvais faire de meppen j'ai perdu
des amis j'ai perdu des amis j'ai perdu
tes phrases et j'étais dans le plaqueur
centre portes et fenêtres federer le bol
de potes qui sent la pisse importé quand
il pleut dans la nuit je me suis levé ce
que j'ai vu ce que je pouvais faire de
mes peurs j'ai perdu des amis j'ai perdu
des amis j'ai perdu des phrases et
j'étais bloqué centre portes et fenêtres
de deux heures le bol de pâtes qui sent
la puce importé qu'emploie dans la mire
à porter quand je pleurais veulent
apporter quand je pleure dans la portée
contre eux non
[Musique]
où
ce panneau de moi
toujours sprinter de mousse tu peux te
tuer mais bien je dois copine stone lors
des examens à tusson focal au 14 bis et
j'ai vu palin idole jonny kopp est aux
manettes de mai
pour
tant mieux nous sommes seuls paul noah
de cessole alfetta maldives no oil comme
sean paul
qu'est-ce qu'est ce que nous et santé en
est un
mattel en vigueur when i'm done
pourquoi la fois
[Musique]
cass soc
soit ce fut nommé à nsn eux pour que tu
veux avec ces mots sonnent fort mois que
l'artiste
[Musique]
un instrument tac aux toits que les
connaissent que nous essorer ouanna
[Musique]
maintenant walk alone
pourquoi la fois le mix de son corps des
ponts se défont un stade de france
le toefl
[Musique]
alors celle ci c'est une reprise c'est
une reprise du morceau san d'orelsan
[Musique]
j'dois premiers mois à chaque fois je
crois que j'ai fini je simpara 01 plus
rapide en plus tueur je devais être plus
mûr j'ai dû me tromper de futur
j'aimerais oublie la magie du tbm
fonctionne qu un coeur n'y est plus ça
fait mal à la fierté j'ai du mal à
l'admettre mais j'ai jamais été aussi
perdu le monde d'un pmu ou n'importe qui
tonnent son mauvais point de vue ou la
télé poste est en faute et ja vu contre
éclair a toujours des sens qu'on écoute
même plus j'essaie de tri entre les deux
pointures et mongole [ __ ] je sais plus
au public c'est de vite et reste
d'actualité sont devenus ma propre
téléréalité je pas rester figé piège
dans mon personnage comme une prise
d'otages à disney malfi d'art comme un
vieux punk
quand tu prends tes potes maintenant le
chauffeur ne suis pas chez moi dans la
capitale je continue d'écrire sur une
ville où j'habite pas j'essaie d'être un
homme bien en mesh plus tôt
je crois que c'est juste un génie du mal
je regrette mes vieux t on droit tant
mensonge jusqu'à faisant vraiment de
chalon à chaque seconde
si je laisse mon esprit ce cas dans la
pénombre je pense à me lever en
maintenant être un homme
ce que la vie que j'ai choisie est la
pomme fiable avoir construit quelque
chose de stable
je suis qu'un seul gauche sur un château
de seule marque de faire un sacrifice
pour des petites gloires serons nous
avons savouré la victoire
l'émission blanche musique des morts ce
qui me choque faut que j'arrête de boire
on les sent plus de gueule de bois
poursuit le maître un bébé dans les bois
j'ai déjà du mal à m'occuper de moi je
cède à 3 pour faire des choix et faire
plaisir à tous dans la sphère la famille
n'ait jamais nos amis de la famille
l'offre lui et ses amis les amis des
amis dit bastien un public qui n'aurait
pas bien mais qui croit toujours à
tatort du craquage est de toiles du
potage de cape town pas si tu vends
marchait dans la rue en pyjama
c'est simplement
[Musique]
cosmo
mais
au bout
avenue
[Musique]
non
s p a
que ça m'a dit on
10 en émoi
[Musique]
pour aggraver suspens
soit nos sites sont mis d'eux et xoom
soit pokola de ce
non mais
on a
mario matt aut
mais oh
et
programme cisco
n'est ce pas
quand
photo tu te donnes comment ce match de
metz machelon demi à me serge july 2
[Musique]
fort de mathieu se
peu
enfant du top
dans le match mais ce match est l'un des
meilleurs le seul genre
ce bal peu
vacances et musical offre est la pensée
musicale
[Musique]
dans l'attentât
maintenant
c'est dans ce cas là
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on
oui
non
[Musique]
on
non
[Musique]
oui
non
moi
[Musique]
et
beaucoup non
[Musique]
où
oui
oh
[Musique]
tu sors on a dansé au son
week-end
[Musique]
non
rappaz
[Musique]
on
m
[Musique]
soit
je vous
m
pour les tories
[Musique]
là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce que tu d'écouté
qui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh [ __ ]
vahirua
non
[Musique]
x
non
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
et
[Musique]
oh
m
[Musique]
là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
e
ah ah
[Musique]
ah ah ah ah
et
là
[Musique]
et
je
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
e
oh
[Musique]
bon
non
[Musique]
oui
e
le
[Musique]
on
le
[Musique]
je
[Applaudissements]
du coup
m
[Musique]
où
monde
[Musique]
il
pour lui
[Musique]
elle
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous
[Musique]
elle
la nuit tombe
tu n'es que la nuit euros la nuit sous
clé
la nuit du vide en dessous rouge la nuit
d'une que la 8e rouge leur tour dès la
nuit de 10 de l'ensemble sont tues tu
l'as tu te prélassent dans ses bras
éclectique que la nuit tant à ce gars
est embrasée dans sa chaire alcoolique
à koulkin a connu
a connu 15
que plus tard
dans ce dense sur la cadence se charger
d'une brosse électrique que tu te noies
dans sa romance sous les néons
billétique billétique du plus petit
les petits gars l'outil de la
petite-pierre public
et puis les petits gars
[Musique]
m
je
[Musique]
on
vous
[Musique]
non
boire un coup juste un tapis vert
je viens viens voir échos
[Musique]
est-ce dépendre un articule son stream
chambrer sur son pull piloter mais
pathétique sexy sans l'obstiné
se demandent si leur trempe les yeux
tournés vers les grilles
sans limite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
elle embrasse les filles
il embrasse les faits
et d'entrée
les filles
[Musique]
oui ensemble
il était temps que sur laurent roux
l'impôt lui collant sur les eaux aussi
liant et squelettique et répond julie qu
elle est en transe continental place et
sentimental scintillante cette
mystérieuse un point d'avancé sur
il embrasse les mots
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce n'est même
il embrasse les
et on semble incliner on s'en tape
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
j'ai parfois du temps
des cookies
vite
enfin
je suis là
moi
[Musique]
benkei chez le rat mai
fort
[Musique]
les champs
vendre des frigidaires la fin
[Musique]
oh
je n'embrasse les mecs
hier l'embrassait taux plein
yelle embrasse la fête
et tout le monde s'en moque
[Musique]
salut c'est la sauvage
je sais pas si tu te rappelles deux mois
s'était rencontré en soirée une fois est
en tout cas je vais dire que je pense
fort à toi
en fait j'arrête pas de faire un rêve
voilà je voulais te dire à bientôt
j'espère
[Musique]
[Rires]
on
[Musique]
où
e
non
le
[Musique]
e
mais la lame du mans comme je lui ai
fait l'amour elle est allée secondes
tombant pour quand je lui fais l'amour
[Musique]
ce que je parlais
pour tout est net
et là
quand je lui
kelly est là
[Musique]
e
allez
[Musique]
mais temps
salut c'est encore moi je voulais savoir
si c'était toujours ok ponctuée de la
maison ce soir
en tout cas moi je tu attends avec
impatience et je pense fort à toi donc à
tout à l'heure
[Musique]
là
elle
m
ton plus torrides
oui total donc je doutais ce morceau de
toit semences ou deux mois ce morceau
ce morceau d'autres fois ce morceau de
moi ce morceau de volupté
on
[Musique]
non
tél
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ô toi
mais les
théo
[Musique]
[Rires]
ici
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
aw
[Musique]
à
oh
ah ah
[Musique]
je sais qu outre l'appétit
lorsque je te touche du liskamm instinct
cathy attendant le bouche à bouche ce
que l'on s'était promis j voudrais que
j'te pousse mais c'est plus trop
l'habitude lorsque j'étais bouche des
spaghettis attendant le japon jusque là
on s'était promis mais c'est plus d'un
mais ma réserve d'argent cette loi et
qui se ment
trois continents sous vide
de monter ta vengeance est un plat qui
se mange froid monde srm
désolé faut jeter nom revient partant
paquin
je t'ai scène
en fait il va vraiment se saouler
désir
qui sans pet
je
j'aime
[Musique]
trop occupés chamelles et les promesses
qui s'en mêle tu laisses la fin du boom
quand je te laisse sur le carreau
attendant gauche a vu ce que l'on se
débrouille
j'ai vu tant pis en réserve la vengeance
est un plat qui se mange très laid des
dates mes sentiments
guirauton et m mais justement je paie
mon désir ap
me désolait faut jeter à
je t'aime demain
jeter
succession
je baignoire
oublié au fond du fleuve
[Musique]
salut c'est encore moi tu réponds plus à
mes sms à mes appels
je pense que t'as pas trop envie de me
voir en tout cas je voulais te dire je
m'en veux vraiment pour tout ce que je
t'ai dit je t'ai fait du mal
je voulais vraiment pas je me sens comme
une merde je culpabilise
j'agis
j'ai pensé que ma gueule en fait
j'ai pas fais attention à toi
je voulais que tu saches que je m'excuse
et j'espère que
[Musique]
j'espère que tu perdras un jour
ciao
[Musique]
c'est
ça
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
com
mais tranquille c'est une mort plus
l'air un puissant qui attendent leurs
terres
[Musique]
toxiques comme un reptile qui m'a tendu
les tropiques attaque si jamais le
décroche
aux morts comme un serpent qui
étrangement certes il mord colère mais
perso j attends d art
toxiques comme un reptile du matin je
vais tranquille attaque subtil du jamais
la décrue
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il
[Musique]
danser
tu sers dans mes tourments
[Musique]
pendant ce temps tu ne dessert tu me
désole quand on dessert
certains cancers dans la tête
[Musique]
toujours là furent et le rosaire
avec du centre superviseur
[Musique]
c'est repos
c'est
[Musique]
là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ah ah
qui attend
m
qui m'attend je me pique
[Musique]
pontivy
tous les vins du château
à recycler
tous
si le pic attaque si possible une
semaine des jeux mais le dimanche jamais
le cross je me décourage
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
moi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est
c
[Musique]
ce
là
[Musique]
où
il
[Musique]
trop
comment
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]